thank you
[Music]
okay so for this one
um people wanted us to talk about this
and there's a lot to read about it but
there's all honestly not a whole lot of
um
of really big things to say about it
because the report about this is not
entirely released but you might have
things that you know about this Oh Me Oh
Yeah
oh there's a special Council that was
tasked with investigating the LAPD like
they made a separate Department to look
into this one Internal Affairs yeah
and what their tasked to look over is
they need to uncover the growing threat
of Deputy gangs in the police department
you ever heard about that I know there's
Deputy gay it's been around forever in
the sheriff's department and the
sheriff's department for sure LAPD I
don't know but I'm I'm sure it's
probably is this in um LAPD L.A County
Sheriff L.A County yeah L.A County
Sheriff's Department for sure and
confirmed yeah I think it was um
there was this huge scandal in the 90s
before that there was one with the
Norwalk Sheriff Department I believe or
or one of those right
and uh the Neo-Nazi Yang infiltrated the
police force whoa and they were they
were basically caught
um just they were my their model was to
catch as many black
guys as possible and frame them and put
them to jail all this stuff great
evidence it was like a crazy conspiracy
not a conspiracy but like a real uh
Scandal that went down like they were
planting drugs they were doing and then
damn and also like they had like
swastika tattoos and they're just like
gang members and then from the
leadership all the way down like they
were recruiting and all this stuff and
I'm like dude that was that was a pretty
wild thing in the 90s but yeah when
gangs infiltrate the law enforcement
that shit's crazy some of their um their
Deputy gang names are like there's the
Banditos executioners
Regulators Spartans Reapers Wayside
whities and the 3 000 boys they're all
uh they're all
from different Deputy stations like
Orange County so Banditos is the east
L.A one yeah uh the Spartans I forgot
where they're from but yeah they're
they're all each station has their own
game I'm surprised it took this long to
break out this news
are they all neo-nazis no no maybe the
whities the Banditos are mainly yeah the
banditas are mainly Hispanics it's weak
in the 20s when they made it what about
the Mr 3000s who are they like what why
what Bernie Mac in them
home run derby what what is the what is
like a deputy gang culture like uh
in general so from the little that I've
heard is uh the first requirement
there's three rules you have to do one
you have to have to smoke someone on
duty
the second one you had to have uh
cheated on your wife but you have to
have another member witness it witness
it
um and the third one is another made
member nominates you well because a lot
of it is kind of like Training Day where
it is career driven
so you have to be nominated by someone
else that was already made and then
everybody's got to have like kind of
like some dirt on everybody yeah and
then it's um wow yeah but it's it's like
literally like a mafia almost and they
make they make money by um stealing from
gangs so like they'll do a drug bust
they'll do a gang bus and then they'll
just like the market yeah basically it's
like the shield it's like that Rampart
[__] yeah they were doing all that but
most of it is I mean they're still like
cops right so they're like
the goal is to stay on the books and
progress in a career so most of it is
trying to
be more legit within the confines of the
law yeah so like like I rather instead
of taking half a million from this drug
bust that if I got in trouble I'm gone
and my kids are all [__] you get me
that new detective position that pays an
extra 100 Grand a year for the next 20
years I'd rather have that so it's it's
like a career it's career driven yeah
the rewards are in the promotions yeah I
don't know I'm just talking about rumors
too that I hear but I mean it's not
entirely unfounded I mean there's like
there was one long article that was
detailing The Experience from like a
female person in the department Sheriff
Department yeah in in her account it's
pretty rough too it's like there she was
saying that like they'll pressure like
other women in the department to sleep
with them and if you don't then they
just screw your career over collectively
[__] just stuff like that too yeah yeah
because they're also connected it's not
as like even though that sounds like a
normal regular thing maybe that's oh you
don't excuse me all right yo make sure
you never work again but it's like for
real for real it's like pressure from a
game it's like instant like as she said
as soon as she denied them then like the
entire department ignored her and like
she was just she just had the worst time
the thing is too with her she probably
got close enough for they had that
influence too yeah because our buddy
who's uh in the sheriff like I'd ask him
like did he anyone ever pose any like
whatever to you or like you know because
it's a lot of these things kind of like
with their boy what's his name again the
guy's been in jail oh herc yeah her yeah
you know he's like people play Mind
Games right so it's on both sides so
it's like you did his favorite for me I
just favorite for you you start betting
the rules and then they're like okay
then you're kind of like under my
influence yeah our buddy is so [__]
squeaky clean he's so clean he's
Kryptonite to all these guys don't ask
them I'm like how come you never did
anyone ever because I know they just
everyone knows then I'll just straight
around on people right so he was like so
he had but I know other Sheriff
Department people our our buddy is like
he's so proud of his identity of being a
cop who gave him a jaywalking ticket
yeah
he would give us tickets he's part of
the G-Shock virgin group
virgin but he is the top in his
Department like he crushes it every
single time like he's the kind of guy
that's like where's all the shootings
and actions that's where I'm going and
then he'll be the top dog arresting
everybody because he's like you're wrong
you're wrong you're wrong
he's always like
going and getting promotions now he's a
detective now he's doing this now he's
doing that but it's like he's so to the
books that he won't even use company
[__] for like personal he wouldn't even
write off like things incorrect he
wouldn't bring a pen home dude yeah he's
like that he'll give himself a ticket
but also with the gangs there's good and
bad we're like the good part why they
even form that just like how every game
it's like even Asian Games right it's
like oh we got a status for the
neighborhood for them it's because on so
many uh police departments are so locked
down by politics they feel like they
can't do policing they know they
obviously know this guy's [__] bad in
this neighborhood supplies drugs to all
the kids runs prostitute rings but
because of politics whatever Catch and
Release we can't get rid of him whatever
I see they're they're like well we're
gonna have to do things our way got it
and then what is something we can lock
them up so a lot of these things also
happen in that way
so because of that
um a lot of people
in the police department they almost
feel it as if it's a necessary evil
because they can actually clean up the
neighborhood it just so happens that
they're also benefiting too they're not
blocked by bureaucracy yeah just like
hot nothing is pure black and white it's
like once you feel the power yeah then
they become that too but there is like
good to it so we also need to like to
have a D.A who wants to to do something
about this kind of [__] too or they can
just go like hey we'll take this guy out
and somehow there's we smoke them we
have I don't know what happened he fired
at me you know and then just like
literally in Training Day we're like oh
we'll put the gun in his hand oh [__]
Mr C who was playing in the neighborhood
that we could never put away never get a
search warrant for it shot at us so we
kill or we kill them right right it's
like now we got now we got the guy yeah
and it's just like very good cooperation
between all the members yeah right yeah
yeah they're but they're trying to I
guess like there's a 70 page report
that's out that's um telling kind of
probably has a lot of names in the
receipts everybody
but yeah that's the Ellie County Sheriff
I'm surprised this stuff doesn't happen
more often huh
outside of just like the show oh I bet
there's a lot yeah right I'm sure even
fire has these types of [__] too yeah
probably fire department probably got
some clicks that are dangerous they're
probably just hanging out the firehouse
we're turning the fires on
[__] the um
this is like any organization that like
the Catholic church right like every
couple years we hear more [__] and like
oh no we're cleaning it up now and then
a couple years go by and the cancer
grows again and like oh no we're doing
something about it don't worry that's
exactly what they're calling it is a
Cancer and I guess like timing wise it
sort of makes sense because it's such a
growing disdain for like police and
Authority from uh you know citizens is
there any institution that has power
that is without corruption absolutely
do
at least chopping off the head of the
snake so they don't stay in power too
long so like it's it's almost like
it's inevitable right like things like
this will happen if it's not out in the
open or like they can't effectively do
their job then they're gonna have to be
illegal
um so if there's like
There's issues in the system for uh them
being able to carry out their job or
like let's say they don't get paid
enough because like in other countries
cops are super way more corrupt because
they don't make enough and they're
easily corrupted by drug lords that will
pay them way more or whatever right so
then
once those systems are fixed then we can
guarantee more of a uh I guess like
you could trust the people of authority
I don't know
but then when yeah when is there enough
of a checks and balance
where things like this don't happen but
I almost feel like it will happen
anytime there's unchecked power well
it's hard to it's also hard to say
because like Bart said like some of the
corruption is happening for what they
believe is a greater good so I mean
great things have happened due to
corruption that we have benefited from
the biggest um the biggest reason why
they want to get rid of Villanueva uh
which is the past sheriff is they ask
them like what do you think of all these
gangs in the sheriff's department and
he's like just straight up like bookcase
oh okay Jesus he's like that guy being
asked about the coffee shop all cops
that I know all Sheriff's Department
people this is the obvious answer nah
man nothing nothing they love him
because he's been the one that's been
battling RDA the most and he's the one I
think he's saying which games because he
knows these guys are actually putting
bad guys away versus now the new guy it
seems like everyone thinks he's a [__]
because he's the guy that goes yup we
sure do have games and then he's also
yeah
everyone I don't know too many people
that like the new one uh Luna or
something because he's a nerd yeah he's
a nerd he's outing his own people yeah
but then at the same time he is getting
rid of the games though so it's like I
don't even know dude What's the right
answer um
yeah that's kind of like when you said
that they're like kind of putting away
people that you know because they know
that they'll just get held up by red
tape yeah that's a little playing
evidence on them
[Laughter]
but Luna is one of the people that is
like working very hard to fix this yeah
that's why [__] hate his ass
he's a hall monitor
I feel like every group a secret
organization they feel like they're
necessary and they have to do it for
their own good because everyone has
their own idea of what's right right so
but even our square ass friend [__]
hates Luna
wow because even he sees like I do these
gangs I would never touch them but
they're they do do some good sometimes
yikes to hear that damn that's a pretty
powerful opinion he sent me a video he
so he uh last year two years ago got
promoted to detective so he's like he's
the one that's putting cases together
sending it to judges NBA's and stuff he
sent me a video of his fax machine
coming in and all these cases just
getting declined like 13 of them in a
day
he's like this one clear I had like
literally like fingerprints on the gun
type [__] the clown the client the
client he's like I don't even know what
the [__] I'm doing dude dude imagine
doing all that work just for to get
there I wonder what's happening with the
Wayside whities it's all political
agenda yeah right so at the top why are
they doing that it that's why I want to
know like it's like before they were
catching people now it's just like nah
but why so who are they catching then
dude can I be in the Wayside whities
we'll cut and we'll talk about it
[Music]
foreign